traffic here at the border between
Poland and the Russian exclave of
Kaliningrad has slowed to a trickle for
the last four years people on either
side were able to cross the border
without a permit with no red tape but in
July
Warsaw suspended visa-free traffic
leaving Russian commuters and shoppers
very frustrated what did you get up
against the political system I don't
understand it and I no longer want to
understand it until recently a little
sticker in their passports was all
Russian and Polish citizens needed to
visit each other's countries without
major constraints now Russians have to
pay 35 euros for a temporary visa with
monthly wages averaging at around 500
euros that's a lot of money you have to
get a visa for the whole Schengen area
and that's not easy we have to organise
a special trip to Poland booked a hotel
room or if you have a good friend in
Poland or anywhere else in the EU they
can give you an invitation
local border traffic has helped to bring
people together and boost economic
activity in border towns like barter
[ __ ] sir on the polish side entire
street blocks are now waiting in vain
for cross-border shoppers from
Kaliningrad Robert piotrovsky has seen
sales at his grocery store slump by over
half one's daily middle grannies may I
say they should keep local border
traffic going because of all the trade
it benefits locals here and the Russians
and it's good for small businesses we
all need each other the most obvious
poacher bar bug the big supermarket
chains got used to having mini buses
full of shoppers from Kaliningrad
pulling up at their doors now there are
precious few Russian visitors in town so
looks
we come here because some things are
cheaper than back home especially things
for children one of the top items on
Russian shopping lists has been fresh
fruit and vegetables meat here is
attractively low-priced
especially pork ideally vacuum-packed
for maximum freshness that meat is
supplied by farmers such as Henrik
Basinski in 2014 Russia blocked the
import of pork from the EU in response
to sanctions imposed by the West due to
the Ukraine crisis the fall in price is
caused by the sudden halt in sales
forced the farmer to reduce his stock
from 5,000 animals to just 700 he longs
for a return to the golden age of pork
exports the ban on imports has boosted
pork production in Russia especially in
the Kaliningrad Oblast in some cases
with the assistance of firms in the West
they don't need our meat anymore
everybody thinks the prices for pork
will magically increase once the trade
embargoes have been lifted but that's
not going to happen at the same time due
to their strong showing on Western
markets Polish exports have increased by
over 8% since 2014
despite the Russian embargo necklaces
ketchup or button-up I don't on the map
Russia looks like a huge and attractive
market but when you look at the stats
it's more comparable with Spain the
Russian population doesn't have a lot of
purchasing power is the Shamala as the
people of Kaliningrad continue to face
restrictions the suspension of visa-free
border traffic sees Poland and the EU
moving further away from Russia